is milo yiannopoulos trying to make a  comeback to the public eye  by helping out radical republican  congresswoman marjorie taylor greene we  don't have anything official about this  but milo has now been spotted multiple  times with marjorie taylor green this  would be  i don't know if it's a strange match or  sort of a match made in heaven it really  depends on your perspective what do you  think this is about and do you think  that milo's reputation among the right  obviously he has no reputation that's  positive among the left but can he  rehabilitate his reputation among the  right by hanging out with marjorie  taylor green let me know in the comments